gritando la palabra libertad estos
manifestantes en melbourne australia
expresan su rechazo a las medidas
impuestas para controlar la pandemia de
kobe 19 que consideran una violación a
sus derechos individuales
siento salieron a las calles tras casi
cinco semanas de estrictas medidas de
bloqueo toques de queda nocturnos y
tapabocas obligatorio las autoridades
defienden sus decisiones na wang escribí
acá nadie está abogando por abrir sólo
por unas semanas y si abriéramos
totalmente eso es exactamente lo que
sucedería serían cinco minutos de sol y
luego una tercera ola que posiblemente
será aún más devastadora que la segunda
mujer sadie en escenas similares se
vivieron en roma italia uno de los
países que vivió una de las cuarentenas
más estrictas del mundo
no es culpa de los médicos obviamente
pero dado que no tenían experiencia en
el campo con este virus lo manejaron mal
por lo tanto todas las muertes que
ocurrieron fueron causadas por la forma
en que se manejó el virus en nuestra
opinión para lo que concierne a esta
emergencia fue una manera de crear una
dictadura no solo de salud no sólo una
dictadura italiana sino mundial fue la
llave para entrar porque poco a poco te
hicieron creer que las máscaras te
protege que es una broma porque nunca
ninguna máscara puede proteger a nadie
el país informó este sábado mil 695
nuevos contagios y en escocia cientos de
personas se concentraron frente a las
instalaciones del parlamento denunciando
las preguntas de exageraciones con
respecto a la gravedad de la pandemia